[Music]
45 seconds of Disney and Pixar logos as
usual even though you all have them
memorized at this point I understand the
movie is rewriting prehistory here for
the sake of the story I think it's worth
mentioning the dinosaurs went extinct 66
million years ago and humans started to
do human things around 10 million if
years ago so the movie wants me to
believe that nothing else could have
happened to the dinosaurs within the 50
million years between this moment and
this moment that would have either
killed the dinosaurs or through
evolution altered their appearance so
drastically we wouldn't be able to tell
what is what I guess so - once in for
holy that looks like real can water man
these dinosaurs learn how to grow crops
and some straight ass lines Pixar
expects me to believe that the
Apatosaurus is evolved - presumably have
retractable axes in their tails and
super-strength well but this kind of
evolution it's all under the earth ever
thought humans were necessary at all
they can build a device for seeding they
can certainly build a plough they also
evolved hyper intelligence which raises
the question how are they able to build
tools like this without hands there's no
way they could tail whack that thing to
get it okay we eat the big one we raise
the little ones of slaves but greed
other than surprising the viewers and
the Dino parents is there any reason for
this egg to have been so big when he's
so small because I don't think that
would actually happened also if I was
Arlo's mom I'd be kind of pissed right
now
I pushed out this giant s egg for this
Arlo's siblings come out of their eggs
running and practically flying it Arlo
struggles to take his first steps that's
clawtooth mountain clawtooth mountain
looks very similar to the Expedition
Everest ride at Animal Kingdom not
exactly the same but enough to confuse
some children also these dinosaurs
couldn't decide if it looked like a claw
or tooth so they said it's just called
claw tooth we're all gonna take care of
it together they've been alive for like
two minutes and already have chores we
never see them eat a chicken or an egg
from a chicken
and based on what Arlo eats during
another scene in this movie and science
I can safely assume he's an herbivore so
why are these things even here senri
only keeping them here to teach Arlo a
lesson about fear convenient dead broken
log is convenient mud is not paint mud
washes away in the rain yet this and
every other mark made remains on the
corn silo for the duration of the film
go
fuck you are making your mark apparently
just means doing your job you might be
expecting me to send this Dino Society
placing such a high value on muddy
footprints instead I'm going to send
this massively heavy stone based
structure for standing upright all this
time on four tiny skinny wooden legs
pics are basically stuck alright you
fuckers into this movie you will darling
you just need a little more time how are
these chickens not dead yet if our lo
can't successfully feed them I got an
idea
genuinely surprised the light bulb
didn't appear above his head just before
he said this I don't know Arlo
wake up and no one else in this room
within the same your shot is Arlo here's
that stop it around these lightning bugs
doesn't make the move but lightly waving
a tail over them makes them light up and
fly away this Henry Steele magic I've
seen The Lion King
this will not end well with this single
jump yeah he sets off a pretty looking
Firefly event but he also killed
hundreds of other unsuspecting fireflies
who did not expect him to jump and land
on them right right the dang wilderness
critters coming over the fence eating
our food I thought you said this will
keep them rotten critters from stealing
our food this keeps up we won't have
enough food to survive the winter but
all you keep here is corn its corn the
only food you plan to eat all winter
dianna of other store houses with other
foods that collectively might mostly
cover the shortfall of this one corn
storehouse how can you have farms and
storehouses like this but not have any
goddamn farming sets are you destined to
go extinct regardless of the
circumstances movie expects me to
believe adorable dinosaurs are capable
of this kind of trap building and
critical thinking
despite being you know dinosaurs and
this is how you're gonna finish it yeah
Henry knows that Arlo struggles to feed
the chickens yet he thinks Arlo's
capable of killing shouldn't he be
hiding Arlo was instructed to catch and
kill the critter not keep it from
showing up that's why they built that
trap see I told you you couldn't be
trusted with this jump scare what are
you doing here
Arlo cuts the tree rope but then the kid
climbs out one of the holes in the net
that he totally should have been able to
climb out of earlier as long as you can
find the river you can find your way
home wow that sounds like some
conveniently prescient bull double come
in handy later
Arlo literally trips over the only rock
in the pathway can Arlo
yes I saw Disney's Hercules - yes it's a
hurricane but this river behaves as
though the freaking Hoover Dam exploded
upriver why cuz we need to move fossa
Arlis dad of course well hello Lion King
but I enjoyed you before but did not
expect to see you in dinosaur form and
from the same freaking studio I mean
they just cranked the Lion King up to 11
I wish I had that cliche what was this
kid doing with his eatin corn cobs
before Arlo opened this hole up 30
seconds ago how fortunate for the plot
that he sees a new hole and instead of
being scared like a feral human child he
decides it's an upgrade to wherever he's
been tossing his food waste that's true
but it's also clear case of transference
Arlo ends up in the raging river waters
mostly because he's stupid and has no
spatial awareness though the movie will
try to blame it on the feral manchild
well clearly he's gonna get knocked down
by a rock any second now also he doesn't
drown after this instead he's floated to
the surface to find air another life
getting bullsh rather easily and
conveniently it was very considerate of
the river to place Arlo in the shallow
pool with his head kept above water on a
rock I see that he has bruises maybe
it's just dirt who knows but no cuts or
gashes or open wounds it's one thing for
him to survive but another thing to
survive mostly unscathed the animation
in this movie is phenomenal and I'll
even knock another sin off for it even
though I really don't like this movie
protagonist is really stupid that's what
you get for not having hands Jeep it's
what's for dinner also he's gonna have
to go down at an incline at least as
steep as the one he climbed up right
he's like on top of the world here he's
got nowhere to go but down this whole um
River dip yep he somehow climb from
there to here I know right I mean don't
ever do this many random force berries
are poisonous this movie is a terrible
role model seriously every bone in
Arlo's body is broken at this point
right it looks like we have a 127 hours
situation on our hands well more like
our leg Bruce Almighty moon in the house
y'all have I mentioned how good the
animation is in this film because the
story is terrible
what makes this lizard food and not
another creature they can talk to I'm
not sure who I should feel bad for here
spot isn't great at killing animals
before bringing them to Arlo for
consumption by modern house cat at least
has a common courtesy to kill a mouse
before bringing it to me movies Timon
and Pumbaa stand in predictably offers
the far from home lost protagonist bugs
as food
I'm glad Neander kid figured out Arlo
was an herbivore but still isn't there
like a 60% chance these berries are
poisonous or was I just over warned as a
child this spot got the berries from the
spot before or how was he able to get
there without the Arlo bridge
spot is a distant relative of Darla
Sherman our low survives this fall which
is categorically ah who fucking cares if
you took your young child to this movie
I bet you regret it so are humans in
this version of history dogs one could
argue that the panting is just heavy
breathing and because of the wrestling
match with the snake but he's also
sitting like a dog and his name is
fucking Spock this is dream crusher he
protects me from having unrealistic
goals what does that mean they're
married both Arlo and spot must have
Lance Armstrong steroid level lung
capacity to make these go for creatures
pop out of the ground
the good dinosaur the trouble with
tribbles well he taught him how to human
paddle these two obviously eat some
shady but fortunately for them the only
side effects are hilarious
hallucinations maybe his parents were
wolves that's the only logical
explanation for his continued non
ape-like behavior but based on his
ability to quickly and quietly move
maybe his parents were cats or hobbits
because it's a movie a storm can
literally roll into the area in like
three seconds I used to have a name like
that ones but that was before I started
following this storm so are the
pterodactyls cult members or are they
just religious who is Pixar trying to
warn me to avoid damn Disney hates Ice
Age also that's horrific and how did it
take me this long to see The Lion King
hyena a connection to these three
pterodactyls just like Jurassic Park
sudden t-rex saves the day hey yeah okay
yeah the carnivorous t-rex's are nice
too the smaller defenseless and
potentially delicious creatures because
I guess John Lasseter was tired of
Steven Spielberg's vilification of the
t-rex Longhorns have feathers nope and
neither did velociraptors until 2007
tiny Dino is able to keep up with three
super fast t-rexes somehow howdy
the rustlers are predatory killers and
have no reason to keep our love alive
but sure let's chat well Arlo and we
have the crows from Dumbo
excellent so the pterodactyls are some
sort of religious zealots the T Rexes or
ranchers so rural story Oh type of the
raptors meth addicts could butch just
snap his neck instead of doing all this
throwing wouldn't that eliminate the
problem from happening in the future
tiny horns wolf thing is able to take
down a giant t-rex with no problem
our little continues to conveniently
find things to hide behind
grasshoppers do not double as harmonicas
even prehistoric ones not my tail stuck
between a rock and a hard place
this movie has to 127 hours references
to many one grunt bit me on the face and
a dash of Finding Nemo this is the
Disney Pixar cliches do basically Nash
and Ramsey respond like they've never
heard this story before
Arlo conveniently discovers his ability
to crack his tail like a whip which is
an ability I'm positive would hurt like
hell
is there any reason this wild friend of
our loans has to be humanoid isn't the
entire point of the conceit of the
asteroid missing the earth so that you
can shove dinos and humans together and
then when you do you make the human such
a mongrel that it might as well be a
wolf for prehistoric ferret miraculously
none of these birds took a moment that
seems unnecessarily dangerous Jesus I'm
gonna be really upset if that's a person
because that will mean that all my
theories are false and Pixar decided to
make people dogs in this movie for no
reason yep it's a person we need to get
home Arlo denies his friend the chance
to reconnect with family on his own
quest to reconnect with family in other
words all it was an asshole all the corn
you can eat didn't he have that before
this asshole didn't learn from the last
time he saw this oh no an upside-down
sky shark Ron is also super convenient
in kind of those pterodactyls to dip
their lower fin just below the cloud
line in unison to tip off their presents
also circling like sharks takes the
shark parallel you're going for one step
too far this doesn't pull the savage
child's arms out of their sockets these
things are like the bizarro Eagles from
Lord of the Rings they just show up
suddenly whenever the script needs some
cheap tension
Arlo survives this although given the
movie's previous events perhaps this
shouldn't surprise me also those things
would definitely eat spot well before
Arlo ever got out of this mess to try
and save him they likely split up spots
limbs on the flight back to the nest
main character is having a vision where
his dead father shows up and tells him
what he has to do to embrace his
identity and fulfill his destiny we
gotta go help him
I love him it's okay to love your dog
man just don't love your dog dream dad
melting in the rain is actually pretty
horrific if I had kids I'd be mad at
Disney for scaring them with this
movie's oddly gross imagery Wow the
climax of this movie is taking place at
the same time weird hurricane is passing
directly over the main mountain will
wonders never cease for some reason the
pterodactyls put the human food inside a
hollow tree before trying to eat it I
guess first sport
hey let's steal that food kit and take
him home but then put him in a hiding
place so that we have trouble eating him
brilliant a 500-pound pterodactyl cannot
carry a two-ton Apatosaurus cup tree
knocks these two into the water and they
promptly forget how to fly
Goff also millions of years from now
Arlo's ancestors will make trickshot
YouTube videos already pretty hairy
situation amplified by conveniently
timed super landslide both Arlo and spot
survived the same type of mudslide
disaster and waterfall that killed our
Lowe's father because Arlo is clearly
invincible
no one knew this before more because he
was so fuckin scared he never did
anything of course they both Richard
gimbal themselves into surviving this
somehow movie does that thing where it
tries to make it think someone's dead
even though there's no way they're dead
which is kind of tired and annoying at
this point I guess blowing on someone is
the prehistoric equivalent of Dwayne
Johnson yelling don't you die on me
while doing chest compressions while
white-haired are these Anderson Cooper's
ancestors his and her sisters
that's right spot just Mowgli off with
your new family and that's the story of
how spot led the humans to the silo thus
ensuring their survival and killing off
a good dinosaur family our local Austin
manages to make it back home all while
not really accomplishing anything so he
gets to finally make his mark whatever
that means
ever since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
[Music]
you would not believe your eyes if ten
million fireflies squirrel
[Music]
shuri buddy I'd be happy to help out
what can I do
well well technically I'm not exactly a
masterbuilder yet watch frankenbean
super chocolate scoop of vanilla don't
waste my time